et l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennelle sur la proposition de loi en
deuxième lecture visant à protéger les
logements contre l'occupation illicites
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien taché
pour le groupe écologiste et pour 5
minutes
merci madame la Présidente sur le
rapporteur chers collègues nous voilà
rendu au vote solaire sur cette loi que
j'ai déjà qualifié de PPL cnews une
proposition de loi honteuse qui vient en
réaction ou seulement 170k de squats
dans notre pays que la droite et
l'extrême droite récupère et utilise
pour stigmatiser les plus pauvres ou les
étrangers alors je redemande une énième
fois une dernière fois chers collègues
comment avons pu en arriver là comment
un président de la République illustre
la bannière du progressisme et qui avait
dit en 2017 qu'il n'y aurait bientôt
plus personne à la rue peut-il
aujourd'hui préférer criminaliser la
pauvreté plutôt que de chercher à
l'éradiquer comment une majorité comme
la vôtre peut-être en arriver à sa dial
à droite et au rassemblement national
pour voter un texte si indigne et
préoccupant pour le droit au logement
alors que 4 millions de personnes sont
mal logées dans notre pays preuve s'il
en fallait une que désormais chers
collègues vous tenez cette fameuse
majorité derrière laquelle votre
première ministre court
nous avons donc à nous prononcer sur
votre terrible loi seulement trois jours
après la fin de la trêve hivernale
échéance vraiment bien choisie pour
permettre à nouveau d'expulser les
locataires poursuivis pour loyer impayés
c'est d'ailleurs déjà ce qui est en
train de se passer sur le terrain les
bailleurs ayant anticipé là-dessus de
votre texte alors je voudrais une
nouvelle fois rappeler à toutes celles
et ceux qui s'apprêtent à voter pour ce
texte que la minorité présidentielle
était prête à envoyer en prison les
personnes en incapacité de payer leur
loyer il aura fallu que ce soit le Sénat
dont la majorité est à droite qui
reviennent grâce aux écologistes sur la
volonté de sanctionner d'une peine de 6
mois de prison des locataires occupant
toujours un logement en situation de
loyer impayés pour que cette disposition
soit supprimée néanmoins vous avez eu la
ment très lourde pour ce que vous nommez
des squatteurs qui seront désormais
passifs de trois ans de prison et de
45000 euros d'amende rappelons qu'une
femme et ses enfants qui iraient
s'abriter dans un garage ou un local
commercial inoccupé entre dans cette
définition et risquerait jusqu'à deux
ans de prison je vous le dis tout net
c'est tout simplement répugnant
chers collègues de la majorité il y a
tant à faire pour le logement dans notre
pays je n'arrive toujours pas à
comprendre que votre priorité numéro 1
le premier texte que vous déposez sur le
sujet soit une loi pour défendre les
multipropriétaires dans son dernier
rapport la Fondation Abbé Pierre a
recensé 4 millions de personnes en
situation de mal logement et 300000
personnes sont domicile et d'ailleurs
opposé à ce texte parce que monsieur le
rapporteur ce n'est pas seulement les
écologistes ou la France insoumise qui
sont posées à ce texte c'est bien toutes
les associations qui viennent en elle au
mal logé votre loi finalement elle
s'inscrit dans une série d'attaques
menée par le droit contre le droit au
logement depuis maintenant des années
elle s'inscrit également dans un
contexte où la production annuelle de
logements sociaux sous Emmanuel Macron
s'est effondré sans 123000 logements en
2016 seulement 95000 chaque année depuis
la mise en place de l'ARS mais qu'est-ce
que vous vous faites et bien vous mettez
à la rue des personnes en situation de
précarité extrême en raccourcissant les
délais pour régler des loyers impayés de
deux mois à 6 semaines après passage
d'un huissier alors je le demande encore
comment pouvez-vous avoir fait de cette
loi votre priorité alors que c'est 1600
enfants qui ont eu à dormir à la rue
faute d'avoir trouvé une place dans un
hébergement d'urgence mes chers
collègues votre loi ne masquera pas
l'échec du président de la République en
matière de logement depuis son arrivée
au pouvoir un échec pour loger un échec
pour reloger un échec pour rénover et je
le dis d'autant que dans ma
circonscription 8100 logements sont
étiquetés comme des passoires
énergétiques j'ai récemment organisé une
réunion publique sur le mal logement à
Cergy et je vous le dis nous sommes face
à une véritable bombe à retardement
soyez en certains le flop du dispositif
m'a prime rénov dans moins de 50 000 ont
été distribués ne pourra pas être
masquée par votre loi votre échec est
partout vous choisissez des loyers
impayés alors qu'il faudrait commencer
par mieux les encadrer samedi dernier ce
sont 3500 personnes qui ont manifesté à
Bayonne contre la spéculation
immobilière et pour un encadrement des
loyers comme le rapporte le média
reporter à Saint-Jean-de-Luz ou Biarritz
le prix des logements atteignent des
sommets frelon parfois les 8 ou 10000
euros le mètre carré on peut également
lire dans cet article que les agents de
l'hôpital de Bayonne dans leur voiture
sur le parking de l'établissement faute
de pouvoir accéder à un logement mais
vous quel est votre priorité mettre en
place une clause de résiliation de plein
que le propriétaire pourra activer sans
avoir engagé une action en justice vous
êtes vraiment désespérant chers
collègues la France ne sonore pas ces
temps-ci et le monde nous regarde après
que le nous est rappelé alors sur les
violences policières leur rapporteur
spécial de l'ONU l'ONU sur le sur le
logement et le Rapporteur spécial sur
l'extrême pauvreté et les droits humains
vous ont adressé un courrier pour leur
dire pour vous dire leur inquiétude face
à votre position votre proposition de
loi ils alertent sur la régression qui
constituent votre texte et sur le risque
qu'elle conduise la France à violer ses
engagements internationaux gouverner
c'est d'abord loger son peuple souvent
répété ces mots de l'abbé Pierre sont
plus que jamais d'actualité mais plutôt
que logé vous préférez réprimer votre
proposition de loi ne fait que mettre
les tapis les vrais enjeux sous le tapis
les vrais enjeux du logement aujourd'hui
nous écologistes préférerions nous
attaquer à ces enjeux là à la racine en
proposant par exemple une garantie
universelle déloyée c'est une question
de droit et de dignité alors chers
collègues du groupe de la majorité des
républicains du rassemblement national
vous qui vous apprêtez à voter cette loi
je vous le dis simplement la priorité
elle était vraiment ailleurs pour le
logement monsieur le ministre voilà
pourtant malheureusement ce qui
constituera l'essentiel de votre bilan
c'est absolument totalement révoltant et
c'est pour ça que le groupe écologiste
s'opposera fermement à ce texte merci
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane peu pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine nu mais
pour 5 minutes
madame madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
cher collègue
régressive quel autre mot utilisé pour
qualifier la proposition de loi que nous
examinons cet après-midi tout au long de
l'examen de ce texte nous n'avons eu de
cesse de vous alerter mais comme à votre
habitude vous n'entendez pas plus que
vous n'écoutez
occupé que vous êtes à nous raconter une
fable une femme de plus pour tenir les
Français à l'écart de la réalité la plus
cruelle le bilan catastrophique de votre
politique du logement jamais aussi peu
de logements n'ont été construits dans
notre pays jamais nous n'avons compté un
nombre aussi important de mal logé et de
sans logis jamais la crise du logement
n'a été aussi forte entraînant une
hausse constante de la part du budget
des ménages consacré consacré à ce poste
mais loin d'apporter des réponses à
cette situation vous propose un texte
qui au prétexte de lutter contre le
squat vise en réalité les personnes qui
des difficultés pour payer leur loyer
c'est un comble un comble également que
ce soit la droite sénatoriale qui est
tenté de supprimer les aspects les plus
extrémistes de votre proposition
initiale qui était davantage marqué du
saut de l'extrême droite que par votre
prétendu centralité votre texte vient
ainsi rompre avec 30 ans d'une politique
sociale par laquelle tous les
gouvernements successifs de droite comme
de gauche ont essayé de concilier les
droits des propriétaires avec ceux des
locataires en cet instant j'ai une
pensée notamment pour Jean-Louis Borloo
qui doit être bien triste en nous voyant
légiférer ainsi lui qui en
responsabilité a bien compris qu'une
autre voie a été possible celle de
l'équilibre en mettant en place des
protocoles d'accord entre propriétaires
locataires et l'état des protocoles des
protocoles de cohésion sociale
permettant de maintenir un locataire en
difficulté de paiement dans son logement
tout en garantissant des revenus aux
propriétaires résumons votre proposition
de loi va entraîner un incroyable
déséquilibre parce que à vos yeux le
monde est binaire un propriétaire a
toujours a priori raison et un locataire
a priori tort partant de là vous offrez
un immense cadeau au marchand de sommeil
et en même temps que vous fragilisez un
peu plus encore les ménages qui
souffrent déjà de la crise du pouvoir
d'achat sur le sujet du logement il n'y
a pas d'un côté les idéologues et de
l'autre les pragmatiques faut-il
rappeler que la moitié des membres de
votre gouvernement n'ont jamais été élus
ni même exercée de responsabilités
publiques et moi je vous le dis en tant
qu'élu locale depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années ancré dans mon
territoire et dans les quartiers
populaires j'ai une vision pragmatique
de la question du logement c'est ce qui
me pousse à rechercher un équilibre
entre les droits des propriétaires et
ceux des locataires je ne souhaite pas
que notre pays soit encore un peu plus
fracturé ni que le désordre et la misère
s'y installe or vos lois veulent
toujours ce cours des possédants et des
puissants et ce texte n'échappe pas ce
principe avec mon groupe nous nous
mettons une fois de plus en garde cette
loi est une honte à notre pacte
républicain et à sa promesse d'égalité
c'est pourquoi évidemment nous voterons
contre ce texte
merci monsieur le député la parole est
un monsieur Paul Molac pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et pour 5 minutes
la présidente monsieur les ministres
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
donc la question qui se pose nous
aujourd'hui c'est celle de la
conciliation entre le droit de propriété
et le droit au logement
nous le savons la juste mesure entre ces
deux droits n'est pas toujours facile à
trouver et souvent le législateur penche
d'un côté ou d'un autre au fur et au fur
et à mesure des majorités quelquefois
même des fêtes d'actualité
au risque de perdre de vue ce qui
devrait lui servir de boussole la
recherche de l'équilibre entre ces
intérêts qui peuvent parfois apparaître
comme contradictoire
nous ne pouvons tolérer effectivement
que certains tirent profit des failles
de notre droit pour se maintenir dans
des logements qui ne leur appartiennent
pas
pas plus que nous ne devons nous
résoudre aux quatre millions de
personnes mal logées et aux 300 000 sans
domicile fixe aujourd'hui nous
partageons votre volonté de défendre les
propriétaires
ceux qui ont investi dans la pierre ont
pris parfois d'une vie entière de labeur
ont le droit de bénéficier de leur bien
mais nous regrettons le silence de cette
majorité sur un autre sujet central qui
est le mal logement que faites-vous pour
ceux qui n'ont pas de chez eux alors que
certains se retrouvent pris entre les
taux des charges locatives à la hausse
et des revenus en berne comment
allons-nous faire pour les aider face
aux zones tendues qui se déploient sur
de nouveaux territoires et l'attribution
des logements permanents en zone
touristique quel est votre feuille de
route où est passé le choc de l'offre
tant promis monsieur le ministre le
manque d'ambition
disponible et abordable se fait de plus
en plus criant la politique du logement
aujourd'hui est dans une impasse les
Français attendent votre plan d'action
pour en sortir
revenons au fond de cette propriété
cette proposition de loi le texte
initial semblait à certains égards
déconnecter des réalités du terrain il
entretenait une confusion dangereuse
entre les squatteurs et les locataires
défaillants
pourtant ce sont deux situations très
différentes nous ne pouvons mettre dans
la même case ceux qui choisissent
d'occuper un domicile qui n'est pas le
leur et ceux qui cessent de payer parce
qu'ils n'ont parfois pas d'autre choix
fort heureusement les sénateurs ont
opéré un nécessaire travail de
clarification le locataire qui se
maintient dans les lieux après la
résiliation de son bail ne sera pas
soumis au même modalités d'expulsion que
le squatteur
nous ne partageons pas non plus notre
volonté de criminaliser certains
individus en grande difficulté via la
création d'un délit d'occupation
syndrome Ittre là aussi la navette
parlementaire aura permis de revenir à
un texte plus équilibré
le vote relatif le volet relatif pardon
au squatteur comporte désormais un
ensemble de mesures qui vise à combler
les lacunes du droit existant et
accroître les sanctions le contre de
ceux qui s'approprient des logements
nous y sommes favorables
concernant les dispositions relatives au
rapport locatif des progrès ont été
réalisés concernant l'accompagnement
social des locataires le texte renforcer
le rôle des commissions de coordination
d'action de prévention des explications
des expulsions locatives grâce au
chapitre ajouté par le Sénat elles
auront un plus grand pouvoir de décision
par exemple s'agissant du maintien des
aides personnelles au logement nous
sommes favorables en outre à la
transmission systématique par l'huissier
de justice du commandement à payer à
cette fameuse commission afin de
privilégier la prise en charge le plus
en aval possible des difficultés du
locataire c'est un premier cas
nécessaire pour accompagner ceux qui
sont en difficulté rappelons toutefois
que ces mesures ne pourront être auprès
opérationnel qu'à condition que les
services sociaux et la Commission en
question dispose d'effectifs suffisants
autre axe du projet de loi la réduction
des délais dans la procédure
contentieuse du traitement des impayés
de loyer là aussi nous redoutons que la
volonté d'accélérer ne s'accompagne pas
des moyens suffisants pour permettre un
accompagnement en temps et en heure des
locataires en difficulté
donc dans mon groupe considère
considérant que c'est ne pas au petit
propriétaire d'endosser les conséquences
de la crise du logement et de la
politique défaillante de Gouvernement en
la matière une majorité d'entre nous
votre a donc en faveur de cette
proposition de loi même si certains
s'inquiètent de certaines dispositions à
croissant les difficultés des locataires
paupérisés feront le choix de s'abstenir
je vous remercie merci Monsieur député
la parole est à Monsieur Paul midi pour
le groupe Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues la
proposition de loi que nous votons
aujourd'hui grâce au président Guillaume
kasbariian vise à protéger les petits
propriétaires contre les squatteurs qui
utilisent les failles de notre droit
pour s'approprier le bien d'autrui elle
ne vise pas à rendre la vie des petits
locataires en galère passagère plus
compliqué quand ils sont de bonne foi
ils sont et doivent rester légitimement
protégés par notre droit
cette proposition de loi elle ne
constitue pas non plus en elle-même
notre politique du logement notre
politique de logement elle s'appuie sur
la construction de logements sur le
développement du logement social sur la
lutte contre le mal logement sur le
développement de l'accès à la propriété
et sur l'accélération de la rénovation
énergétique pour cela nous avons un
gouvernement et un ministre que je salue
mobilisé et des moyens alloués en
augmentation en 2022 à 17 milliards
d'euros
alors je pense en particulier au députés
de la France insoumise qui défendent le
squat qui considère que le squat peut
faire partie d'une politique du logement
qui considère que donner comme
perspective à quelqu'un qui galère à se
loger de s'approprier le bien autrui par
la force ou la contrainte peut faire
office de politique publique en
défendant le squat vous démontrez une
fois de plus votre volonté d'inverser
les valeurs
d'inverser les valeurs inscrites dans
notre Constitution ou dans notre
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen d'inverser toutes les valeurs
communes que nous partageons dans notre
République aujourd'hui défendre les
squatteurs face aux petits propriétaires
c'est défendre l'inverse de l'article 17
de notre Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen
qui dit que la propriété est atteint
droit inviolable et sacré nul ne peut en
être privé quand vous défendez les
casseurs face aux forces de l'ordre vous
défendez l'inverse de l'article 2 de
notre Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen qui consacrent la sûreté
et la sécurité comme droit naturel et
imprescriptible de l'homme
quand vous encouragez une manifestation
illégale à Sainte Soline
vous défendez l'inverse de l'article 10
de notre Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen qui dit que nul ne
doit être inquiété pour ses opinions
même religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestation ne troublent pas l'ordre
public établi par la loi
quand vous remettez en cause nos
processus institutionnels et le résultat
des élections par la voie de votre chef
Monsieur Mélenchon vous défendez
l'inverse de l'article 3 de notre
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
et quand vous dressez des listes d'élus
à menacer ou à vilipander vous défendez
l'inverse de l'article 7 de notre
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen en défendant l'inverse de notre
socle de valeur démocratique et
républicaine vous semez la confusion
dans le débat public et dans l'esprit de
certains de nos concitoyens je crains
que vous ne le fassiez pas seulement
pour faire le buzz sur les réseaux
sociaux mais pour ça paie consciemment
les fondements de notre système actuel
que vous voulez renverser par vos
actions trop souvent violentes plutôt
que par les urnes là où votre chef
Monsieur Mélenchon a échoué trois fois
de suite
alors je le dis à nos concitoyens soyons
très attentifs à ce qui se passe ici à
l'extrême gauche comme à l'extrême
droite et compter sur nous pour défendre
nos valeurs démocratiques et
républicaines sur le fond des idées sans
hurler sans insulter sans violence sans
appel à la violence et dans le cadre de
nos institutions démocratiques et
républicaines et pour ce qui est du vote
à venir nous allons défendre à la valeur
du droit de propriété pour tous car
c'est un acquis de notre histoire
commune quand il n'y a pas de droit de
propriété pour tous alors tout
appartient au même c'est à dire au
tirant ou à une caste de privilégié et
c'est tout l'inverse de nos valeurs
démocratiques et républicaines et de ce
pourquoi nous nous battons merci à tous
merci Monsieur député ma parole est à
Monsieur Michael taverne pour le groupe
rassemblement national et pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres madame à la vice-président de
commissions monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues aujourd'hui nous sommes
donc amenés à nous prononcer une
deuxième fois sur cette proposition de
loi visant à protéger les logements
contre l'occupation illicite ce texte
considérablement enrichi comme nous
avons pu le dire la semaine dernière au
cours de nos travaux mais aussi par le
Sénat constitue le début d'une réponse
plus qu'attendue par nom de nos
concitoyens au fléau du squat en effet
il n'est pas
inutile de rappeler les nombreux faits
divers liés à cet acte délictuel
particulièrement traumatisant pour les
victimes pour mesurer l'urgence à
légiférer en la matière
au cours des débats le groupe
rassemblement national a ainsi pu
rappeler son engagement de longue date
sur ce sujet avec notamment le dépôt
d'une proposition de loi par notre
présidente Marine Le Pen lors de la
précédente législature en mars 2021 si
les améliorations que nous jugeons
nécessaires et que nous avons proposé
d'adopter ont été rejetés il est certain
que nous n'en prenons pas ombrage aussi
bien que nous puissions pointer des
lacunes notamment quand on protection
apportées aux propriétaires victimes de
squats en matière civile nous nous
dérangerons pas à notre cohérence et
nous soutiendrons l'adoption de ce texte
perfectible certes mais nécessaire
soyez néanmoins certains que nous ne
manquerons pas de proposer de nouveau
les mesures que nous souhaitions
adjoindre à ce texte lorsque l'occasion
se présentera en outre nous saluons les
mesures complémentaires prévues par le
texte notamment celle visant à aider les
locataires en difficulté car elle est
évident que la lutte contre le squat ne
peut se faire sans de tel mesure ainsi
je le disais ce débat a été l'occasion
de mettre en avant notre cohérence mais
il a également une nouvelle fois
démontré l'un dont l'extrême gauche en
effet il est révélateur de voir
l'extrême gauche nupes s'opposé
fermement à ce texte elle qui préfère
toujours le délinquant à la victime qui
est les propriétaires et qui au fond ne
semble pas avoir de problèmes à ce qu'un
bien soit spolié peu importe la méthode
comment donc pouvez-vous vous
revendiquer sans cesse de la Révolution
française et de ses acquis quand vous
confortez dans le même temps ceux qui
mettent à mal le droit de propriété
droit fondamental consacré par la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen
vous le voyez sur ce vous le voyez sur
ce sujet nous avons toutes les raisons
de rappeler que votre républicanisme
n'est qu'une façade et les Français le
voient jour après jour
quoi qu'il en soit il est certain que
les propriétaires victimes de ces
occupations illicites qui sont je le
rappelle une fois encore les petits
propriétaires issus de la classe moyenne
accueilleront avec satisfaction ce texte
pour eux il était nécessaire de mettre
fin au calvaire que représente les mois
voire les années de procédure pour
finalement retrouver leurs biens trop
souvent fortement dégradé et sans que la
dette locative accumulée ne leur soit
parfois remboursé s'il n'est pas
acceptable qu'en France autant de nos
compatriotes éprouvent de grandes
difficultés à se loger laisser prospérer
le squat n'est pas une solution comme
semble le croire l'extrême gauche mes
chers collègues nous l'avons rappelé le
droit de propriété est un droit
fondamental et de ce fait il mérite que
lui soit apporté toutes les garanties
nécessaires et que toute la force de la
loi le protège ainsi comme toujours
lorsqu'il s'agit de défendre les
libertés et les droits fondamentaux les
élus du rassemble répondront présent et
votre ont donc en faveur de ce texte je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur François Piquemal pour le
groupe la France insoumise nue et pour 5
minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur la
violence Benjamin 49 ans à Toulouse la
violence Catherine 60 ans à Lille la
violence Mohamed 22 ans à Paris la
violence Charlotte 33 ans à Orléans la
violence de votre monde celui où vous
versez plus de larmes devant une
poubelle qui brûle que devant les vies
qui s'éteignent chaque année dans nos
ruelles
623 à minima en 2021 dans un pays qui
compte 3 millions de logements vides 14
millions de personnes touchées par la
crise du logement 330000 sans abris 42
000 enfants SDF vous auriez pu proposer
face à ce constat une loi d'urgence sur
le logement avec l'encadrement à la
baisse des loyers la revalorisation des
appels relancer la construction de
logements sociaux et la loi de
réquisition rien de tout cela l'histoire
retiendra qu'en 2023 4 jours après la
[Applaudissements]
un criminel potentiel y compris les
victimes de marchands de sommeil une loi
violente pour les locataires qui ne
parviennent pas à s'en sortir en
diminuant les délais de paiement en
pleine période d'inflation et en
limitant les pouvoirs des juges sur ces
derniers une loi violente aussi pour les
petits propriétaires à qui vous faites
croire qu'elle va améliorer leurs
problèmes face à un phénomène marginal
le squat alors qu'elle va juste les
plonger dans les méandres du manque de
moyens de la justice que vous entretenez
avec votre politique d'austérité on
notera que quand nous vous avons proposé
des mesures plus coercitives sur les
assurances d'impayés pour qu'elles les
rembourse ou de mettre en place la
garantie universelle des loyers leur
permettant d'être remboursé en cas
d'impayés vous avez ici tous refusé
votre but n'est pas de protéger les
petits propriétaires bailleurs mais les
multipropriétaires et le monde de
l'assurance privée toujours les mêmes
nous voulons penser à toutes ces
familles qui se retrouvent devant le
stress des factures des salaires qui
stagnent des frigos vides des fins de
moi qu'on ne peut plus boucler et qui
avec votre loi seront en plus soumises à
la pression d'amande voire de prison
nous sommes avec elle celles et ceux qui
ne sont rien pour la macronie sont tout
pour nous votre loi est si violente que
comme pour la réforme des retraites vous
avez réussi à vous mettre tout le monde
ado la Défenseur des droits amnesia
international le Secours Catholique
trois ou logement CNL UNICEF Fondation
Abbé Pierre et aujourd'hui l'ONU
violente comme votre fut d'écouter ses
associations eweng les personnes
travaillant dans les commissariats
d'expulsion les travailleuses sociales
les magistrats et même les agents de
police que vous allez envoyer faire le
sale boulot des expulsions à votre place
ne vous en déplaise le logement n'est
pas pour l'immense majorité de la
population un moyen de se faire de
l'argent comme votre philosophie conduit
à le penser il est le socle d'un
ensemble de liberté fondamentale comme
les principes du droit à la vie privée
de droits socio et politiques comme le
droit de vote le droit à l'intimité à
avoir un lieu pour soi et ses proches le
droit à la dignité c'est à tous ces
principes et ses droits que s'attaque
votre loi finissons avec les mots de
celui qui ayant toujours combattu
l'extrême droite a dû se retourner entre
ses quatre planches plus d'une fois en
vous entendant limité de son vivant
d'ailleurs avec votre loi il aurait fini
entre 4 murs c'est d'une prison pour
avoir soutenu les sans-abris qui
occupaient des bâtiments vides bien sûr
il s'agit de l'Abbé Pierre
il y a une loi avant les lois pour venir
en aide à un humain sans toi sans pain
privé de soin il faut braver toutes les
lois je suis sûr qu'il aurait bravé
celle-ci
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Annie Geneva pour
le groupe les républicains et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
vice-présidente de la Commission
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
au moment où nous nous apprêtons à voter
la loi visant à protéger contre
l'occupation illicite les logements les
locaux à usage d'habitation ou à usage
économique les républicains tiennent à
redire qu'ils sont très favorables à ce
que l'on légifère sur cette question dès
2018 nous nous sommes emparés de ce
sujet que l'actualité alimente
régulièrement avec son lot de drame de
situation totalement contraire à l'État
de droit et qui est l'âge ne dure que
trop encouragé par des procédures
incertaines par des squatteurs qui en
utilisent toutes les failles et par des
pouvoirs publics démunis ou trop lents
les débats ont beaucoup tourné autour de
la distinction nécessaire entre
squatteur et locataires et entre
locataires malveillant et locataire
démuni je pense que les amendements
apportés au texte par la majorité
sénatoriale et par nos travaux à
l'Assemblée ont contribué à clarifier
les choses
je regrette que du côté de la France
insoumise nos collègues ne se soient
livrés à une vision totalement
manichéenne et forcément déséquilibrée
entre propriétaires accusées de tous les
mots et locataires ou squatteurs
forcément victimes le squat le squat ne
peut pas être une solution de logement
digne pour les plus démunis oui il faut
rappeler que la propriété a une valeur
constitutionnelle c'est un droit
inviolable et sacré inscrit dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen vous avez dans une approche
marxiste datée cherché à assimiler la
propriété à du vol selon la formule bien
connue pour nous c'est le squat qui est
du vol et si le terme de vol n'a pas été
explicitement repris dans le texte pour
des raisons légistiques l'idée est bien
là
dans toutes vos interventions mes chers
collègues c'est la figure du multiple
propriétaire à vide et insensible à la
misère que vous avez cherché à imposer
rappelons que dans notre pays la part de
propriétaire et de 58%. il y a parmi eux
des multipropriétaires cibles de toutes
vos attaques comme si nous n'avions pas
besoin en France d'investisseurs
particulier ou non qui alimente le
marché locatif mais une grande partie
des propriétaires s'avèrent en réalité
être modeste et leur investissement
s'avère être le résultat d'une vie
d'efforts et d'économies quand on
propriétaire marchand de sommeil cette
loi le cible et c'est bien normal les
républicains ont apporté à ce débat une
contribution active et je crois
déterminante particulièrement sur la
question du squat nous lui avons donné
une claire définition juridique comme
étant l'introduction sans droit ni titre
dans un logement
moins local à usage d'habitation ou
économique à l'aide de manœuvres menace
voie de fées ou contrainte nous avons
soutenu ce que j'avais également demandé
dans ma proposition de loi
l'alourdissement du quantum de paix à 3
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amende
pour le squat du domicile nous avons
soutenu les propositions utiles à
faciliter luisante à faciliter
l'expulsion du squatteur comme la
réduction des délais contentieux dans la
voie judiciaire ainsi que l'amélioration
de la procédure d'évacuation forcée dans
l'avoine administrative nous avons
élargi le délit de squat aux locaux à
usage économiques et exonérer le
propriétaire des conséquences d'un
défaut d'entretien résultant du squat le
Sénat a affaibli le quantum de Pen à
deux ans de prison et 30000 euros
d'amende pour le squat à des locaux à
usage d'habitation ou à usage
économiques distinguer du logement
considéré comme étant plus grave ce qui
est à mon sens discutable cela entraîne
en effet un effet de bord qui a pour
résultat que le propriétaire qui
chercherait à récupérer son bien se
verrait davantage pénalisé que le
squatteur lui-même lui-même ce qui vous
en conviendrait et contraire à l'esprit
de justice le squatteur s'en sortirait
mieux que sa victime il n'est à mon sens
pas possible d'en rester là enfin le
squat s'accompagne presque toujours de
dégâts et de dégradation commis pendant
l'occupation ou au moment où le
squatteur en est chassé et c'est au
propriétaire dans l'assumer toutes les
conséquences financières parfois très
lourdes tout comme le paiement des
charges d'un local dont il est privé de
l'usage cette question demeure largement
absente de la loi et je le regrette cela
étant nous avons obtenu des avancées
indéniables ce texte porte désormais
notre marque particulièrement matière de
répression de squat c'est pourquoi les
républicain AINS le voteront je vous
remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur
Eric Martineau pour le groupe démocrate
c'est pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues la propriété
étant un droit inviolable et sacré nul
ne peut en être privé si ce n'est
lorsque la nécessité publique légalement
constaté l'exige évidemment et sous la
condition d'une juste et préalable
indemnité la propriété et la sûreté font
partie des droits qui ont été affirmés
par la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de 1789 comme des droits
naturels et imprescriptibles si nous
devons veiller à ce que ce droit soit
respecté et appliqué pour chacun de nos
concitoyens il est également de notre
rôle de parlementaire d'agir lorsque des
principes aussi fondamentaux de notre
société sont mises à mal
c'est ce que plusieurs de nos collègues
ont fait sur ce sujet de l'occupation
illicite des logements depuis quelques
années et que le président kasbariian a
permis d'inscrire à l'ordre du jour de
notre assemblée
aucun d'entre nous ne peut rester
insensible face au récits de
propriétaires impuissants privés de
l'horlogements du jour au lendemain car
des inconnus ont décidé de s'en emparer
dans de nombreux cas c'est le fruit du
travail d'une vie dont ces Français sont
privés mais nous parlons bien d'ici de
squats et non pas de locataires qui par
des difficultés de la vie ne
parviendrait plus à payer leur loyer ce
sujet est complexe et sensible tant il
affecte des vies et révèle du désespoir
et de l'impuissance d'un côté comme de
l'autre vous avez souhaité avec ce texte
apporté des solutions à cette
impuissance parce qu'un propriétaire
dont le logement est squatté ne peut
être laissé pour compte pendant près de
trois ans parce que la procédure
judiciaire est trop longue ou bien parce
que les préfets ne se prononcent pas ne
prononcent pas une demande d'expulsion
administrative car les solutions de
relog sont insuffisantes à ce titre nous
considérons que ce texte ne peut être
pensé de manière isolée sans une plus
large réflexion autour de l'accès à un
logement digne pour tous travail que
nous menons avec mes collègues du groupe
démocrate
un des enjeux de ce texte est également
de différencier d'une part les quelques
malheureux cas auxquels nous souhaitons
répondre et de l'autre toutes les autres
situations concernant des familles qui
doivent être malgré tout aidé et
accompagnés enfin si la loi doit
protéger chacun d'entre nous aussi peu
nombreux soient-ils nous devons
également veiller à ce que nos lois ne
créent pas d'effet de bord
je pense notamment à l'adoption en
commission en première lecture d'un
amendement portant création d'un délit
d'occupation sans droit ni titre et de
mauvaise foi d'un logement appartenant à
un tiers notre groupe s'y était opposé
considérant que la mauvaise foi est une
notion floue non définie endroit pénal
et surtout que cette mesure renversait
la charge de la preuve et constituée
ainsi une remise en cause de la
présomption d'innocence il s'agissait
finalement d'une confusion entre
atteinte au droit de la propriété et
atteinte à la vie privée nous modifions
avec cette proposition de loi notre
droit pénal et nous devons rester
vigilants de la même manière certaines
dispositions initialement proposées nous
paraissaient tout bonnement inopérante
qu'il s'agisse d'une lourde augmentation
des sanctions financières alors même que
la personne est dans l'incapacité de
payer un loyer ou injustement
disproportionné
tel qu'une peine de prison pour le
maintien dans les lieux d'un locataire
sous le coup d'une décision définitive
d'expulsion mais la navette
parlementaire et notamment le travail
des sénateurs a permis de rééquilibrer
les dispositions de ce texte en y
intégrant comme le souhaitait mon groupe
une juste distinction entre un squatteur
et un locataire en difficulté ainsi
plusieurs mesures offriront des outils
supplémentaires aux propriétaires
victimes tels que le transfert de la
responsabilité du propriétaire vers
l'occupant sans droit mythitre en cas de
dommage résultant d'un défaut
d'entretien ou encore la pérennisation
de l'expérimentation
issue de la loi élan pour encourager les
occupations intercalaires et ce afin
d'augmenter la capacité de logement
vacants et ainsi faciliter la prise de
décision d'expulsion administrative par
les préfets
l'accélération de la procédure
judiciaire pour un pays et également la
bienvenue dès lors que le délai
d'instruction laissé au préfet pour
mettre en oeuvre un squatteur reste
suffisant au vu de toutes ces évolutions
notre groupe désormais apporter son
soutien sur ce texte et poursuivra son
travail en faveur d'un excès pour tous à
un logement digne je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur ignaki et
tchanice pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs
en préambule de mes propos je
souhaiterais rendre hommage à toutes les
femmes et tous les hommes qu'à travers
des associations des engagements
professionnels ou personnels soutiennent
les personnes à la rue les personnes en
difficulté de paiement et les personnes
expulsées cette proposition de loi est
l'assurance de faire peser sur eux un
plus grand fardeau alors même qu'elles
allaient être sur le manque de moyens
depuis des années la France émaillée
d'acteurs engagés expert volontaire qui
mérite tout notre soutien et notre
reconnaissance pas notre défiance pas
notre aveuglement nous devons être à la
hauteur de la crise qui se joue celle
qui impacte plus de 14 millions de
personnes en France celle qui va
s'aggraver dans les années à venir faute
de logement disponibles face aux
demandes faute de nouvelles unités
construites ou réhabilités faute de
ménage au revenu suffisants pour
s'offrir un loyer un emprunt ou un
logement décent
parallèlement les réformes de
l'assurance chômage du RSA des retraites
et votre refus d'augmenter
significativement le SMIC
votre fut d'augmenter signifie le SMIC
pardon alimente ses situations de
fragilité qui mène à ce que vous
souhaitez combattre les impayés de loyer
et les squats votre argumentaire sont
truffés d'exemple de petits
propriétaires acculés par le coût
exorbitant d'un mauvais payeur de
retraités qui ne peuvent récupérer leur
maison ou de résidence squattées et
détériorées ces situations nous choquent
aussi sur les bancs de la gauche mais
ici il ne s'agit majoritairement pas de
cela quel pourcentage de propriétaires
au pied du mur quel est le pourcentage
de locataires de mauvaise foi je vous ai
posé plusieurs fois la question monsieur
le rapporteur en séance sans jamais
aucune réponse ces faits sont
minoritaires et votre action s'assoit
sur une réalité tronquée qui vient faire
la part belle aux expérimentations de
l'extrême droite la vérité c'est que la
majorité des situations de squats ne
concerne pas le domicile il s'agit
plutôt du squat de structure vacantes 10
fois plus nombreuse que le nombre de SDF
la vérité c'est que cette proposition de
loi va concerner principalement je vous
invite à écouter l'orateur et lui seul à
la parole la vérité c'est que cette
proposition de loi va concerner
principalement les locataires en
difficulté de paiement qui ne
parviennent plus à joindre les deux
bouts l'impact de cette proposition de
loi va engendrer sur les plus précaires
sans solution et telle que l'ensemble
des associations la défenseuse des
droits la CNCDH est maintenant l'ONU
monsieur le rapporteur sont en défaveur
de votre texte en effet combattre les
impayés de loyer et les squats par
l'augmentation des expulsions des
sanctions financières et la crimination
des personnes et non seulement
inutiles puisqu'une personne insolvable
ne sera pas moins après son expulsion
mais surtout contre-productif puisque
précariser des publics déjà fragiles ne
veillera que accentuer ce que vous
souhaitez combattre squat situation
d'impayés occupation d'espace public par
ailleurs le texte ne permettra pas de
restituer le loyer perdu aux
propriétaires en un jour les dettes
locatives en éloignant la sortie de la
précarité pour les ménages fragiles ça
me fait les propriétaires bailleurs
laissaient rien pour lui-même cette
proposition de loi porte donc dans une
logique de punition et non de réparation
pourtant il y avait multitude de
solutions pour agir sur les
problématiques que vous soulevez pour je
vous cite couper court au mouvement de
départ du marché locatif traditionnel
vers celui des meubles de tourisme vous
auriez pu supprimer les niches fiscales
incitant la location courte durée vous
auriez pu renforcer la lutte contre les
pratiques illégales connues comme les
congés pouvant abusifs vous auriez pu
donner des outils aux communes pour
limiter le déferlement des résidences
secondaires nous étions 3500 monsieur le
rapporteur dans les rues de Bayonne
samedi pour dire STOP un ski et pour
défendre le droit au logement pour tous
vous auriez pu pour diminuer le nombre
de loyer incite le loyer impayé inciter
à l'utilisation de la garantie visale
mettre en place la garantie universelle
et obligatoire des loyers vous auriez pu
pour donner les moyens aux Français
modestes d'être logés lutter contre la
hausse des loyers prévoir des outils
d'aide à l'accession comme celui tu
l'appelles accession que le gouvernement
a supprimé activement vous auriez pu
ouvrir des places en logements sociaux
et d'hébergement d'urgence vous auriez
pu lutter réellement contre les
marchands de sommeil sujet que vous avez
volontairement écarté optez pour des
machines des moyens justes et efficaces
étaient possibles vous n'avez pas saisi
cette opportunité quel sera l'avenir des
cent mille personnes en stress financier
ou en impayé de loyer à la suite de
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
comment l'État va-t-il gérer les
conséquences de l'augmentation des
expulsions alors s'il vous plaît je vous
invite à goûter notre orateur d'après
une enquête de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
1 à 3 ans après l'expulsion 32% des
ménages ne retrouve pas de logements
ceux qui sont relogés ont mis en moyenne
11 mois à y parvenir parmi les inquiétés
29% en ampli poursuivre leur activité
professionnelle sans compter l'impact
sur la scolarité des enfants et sur la
santé physique et psychologique des
personnes concernées votre loi va à
l'encon des objectifs de votre plan
logement d'abord mais aussi à l'encon de
vos propres ambitions d'insertion et de
plein emploi
malgré les atténuations proposées par le
Sénat qui a pris le gouvernement sur sa
gauche il faut quand même le souligner
cette proposition de loi va mettre en
danger des milliers de famille ça c'est
vérité et disproportionnée à l'égard des
personnes qui je le rappelle ne sont pas
dans les délinquantes dans la majorité
des cas ce texte ne règle pas la
difficulté la difficulté du logement
mais le déporte et les agréables
puisqu'il traite principalement les
conséquences avant les causes il y avait
1000 choses à faire monsieur le
rapporteur avant cette loi ou votre
rendons contre ce texte merci monsieur
le député
je fais annoncer le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale et
le dernier intervenant et Monsieur Luc
Lamirault pour le groupe horizon
apparenté pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente
je sais bien que cette place en dernier
orateur et pas la plus simple parce que
tout le monde va arriver et vous allez
bien sûr pas m'écouter mais c'est ah
merci à tous
mais on attend encore un petit peu de
monde
madame la Présidente Monsieur le mini
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de commission monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
nous nous rencontrons une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui autour de la proposition de
loi du président Guillaume kasbariian
qui vise à protéger les logements contre
l'occupation illicites et qui vient en
complément du travail qu'il a réalisé
dans le cadre de la loi d'accélération
et de la simplification de l'action
publique voter en 2020
poursuivant son parcours législatif qui
a débuté dans un premier examen en 202
en novembre 2022 nous pouvons
aujourd'hui parler d'un texte enrichi de
nos différents débats tant à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'au Sénat
en effet cette ex permet d'apporter des
réponses concrètes et efficaces en
poursuivant deux objectifs principaux
le premier objectif est de mieux
réprimer le squat des logements par des
sanctions renforcées et un
allergissement de la définition légale
du délit de violation de domicile
en effet
il est vrai si le phénomène du squat
n'est pas massif dans notre pays les
nombreux exemples entendus durant nos
échanges démontre bien la nécessité
d'apporter des solutions aux
propriétaires confrontées par ces
problèmes
le deuxième objectif de cette
proposition de loi est sécurisée les
rapports locatifs en permettant la
résiliation du bail de manière
automatique en cas d'un pays la
réduction des délais pour les procédures
contentes et l'expulsion des occupants
nous espérons à travers ces objectifs je
vous assure on vous entend plus que
l'orateur donc je vous invite à écouter
le dernier orateur de ces explications
de vote merci
vous l'avez bien vu
[Applaudissements]
nous espérons à travers ces objectifs
lever les réticences de certains
propriétaires qui hésitent à mettre en
location leur logement du fait notamment
de leur crainte légitime de ne pas
pouvoir lutter efficacement en cas de
maintien dans les lieux de locataires
refusant de payer leur loyer
certains propriétaires peuvent être des
retraités pour lesquels la mise en
location de leur bien constitue une
ressource de revenus parfois essentiel
ce texte nous en sommes bien conscients
ne résout pas l'ensemble des problèmes
du logement dans notre pays
nous aurons à nous occuper dans les
prochains mois de la crise actuelle du
manque d'offres de la faible création de
nouveaux logements
de deux facteurs ayant une incidence
importante sur les prix des loyers
nous sommes bien conscients du travail
qui nous reste à faire cependant ce
texte était attendu pour répondre aux
situations inadmissibles et difficiles
en conclusion le groupe Horizon est
apparenté tient un salut une nouvelle
fois le travail du rapporteur Guillaume
kasbariian et votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi merci
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous invite à regagner vos
places je vais attendre que tout le
monde
alors je vais mettre au bois la
proposition de loi
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
le scrutin est clos
votant 540 exprimé 5302 majorités 277
pour 385 contre 147 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez la parole
mes chers collègues si vous quittez je
vous invite à le faire en silence et
sans plus regarder soit la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
c'est une première marche mais ce soir
vous avez mis un terme de façon
transpartisane à une injustice que nos
compatriotes ne supportent plus ils sont
en effet révoltés et eux ne confondent
pas les locataires et les squatteurs il
était important de rappeler que les
squatteurs sont des délinquants il est
important que l'on protège les
propriétaires et puis la dernière sauce
que je veux vous dire c'est que je suis
toujours sidéré d'entendre un
parlementaire appelé à la désobéissance
civile c'est-à-dire la désobéissance à
la loi
qui n'est parfois censé voter
merci
monsieur le ministre du Logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je tiens à mon
tour à saluer l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi saluer le travail de
du rapporteur de cette loi Guillaume
kazmarion et de la Vice-Présidente
de la commission des affaires
économiques à de Laurence Petel vous
dire à mon tour que cette loi ne met pas
en opposition les propriétaires et les
locataires que le travail qui a été
effectué sur ses bancs et en commission
a permis d'avoir un résultat équilibré
que bien évidemment comme ça a été
plusieurs fois souligné cette loi ne met
pas du tout un point final au travail
que nous devons continuer à mener tous
ensemble sur le logement et l'accès au
logement du du plus grand nombre nous
continuerons à travailler comme ça et
déjà été fait à continuer à lutter
encore plus contre les marchands de
sommeil et le travail qui a été mené
dans cette proposition de loi nous a
permis d'y travailler encore plus et
nous travaillerons bien évidemment tous
ensemble et je remercie les députés qui
travaillent déjà à lutter contre
l'habitat insalubre et les copropriétés
dégradées encore merci merci Monsieur
ministre la séance est suspendue pour 5
minutes